welcome to this video plane mmm yeah Cat
Stevens sorry not the real cat stevens i
suppose from the UK flag groups of some
canada okay played the tango Black
Knights tango but damn we transpose to
the Zurich variation of them oh let this
to cook check I actually think that
Bishop g5 is the most testing move okay
anyway anyway he played 85 here a 5 or
castles right this other the two moves
yeah I really tend to let forget what
I'm analyzed for my book still work in
progress try to prevent if I for a while
at the end Black will always manage to
to play that move okay I don't to go on
to a now Bishop g4 so I go age three and
now should I just casts on I wonder age
60 sick slightly slightly curious move I
wonder if g-form could be could be an
option or is this completely crazy
it's tempting okay let's try this I
haven't canceled yet so i might as well
cancel long and then go for g4 g5g for
also takes away their five square for
for the bishop yeah yeah I thought maybe
he can play a for Evan okay let's not
spend too much time go in each form
awesome okay
laughs I did my Lord Bishop Bishop d3
sometimes I switch back to German Bishop
d3 attacking the night it all looks a
bit shaky but if he needs to return now
or play any slow move now this is not
exactly slow yeah one problem is if I
move it now to be too he might be able
to play not really and night f2 I
thought but this is not really working
might have to Queen f2 rock III Bishop
e2 and this doesn't really help it leads
to an end game where he's got three
pawns but it's a very bad end game
because his pawns parts are not very
mobile they cannot really take him yeah
yes you need to retreat the night or
maybe there's something with f5 or d5
hmm
we are maybe just a five
5 f-5 I could could even think wow
so Bishop takes rook takes Queen takes
Bishop c6 and he will get you know get
the rook back very nice line okay but
let's let's still go for that anyway at
the end i should be able to to guess
along so f form on yes I get some put
the tempo on the doucher and d6 hang so
probably Bishop g2
Bishop g2 it's eric g one Bishop g2
somehow some others who feels wrong get
this also feels wrong but but how do you
find now come on let's let's open it up
g6 the mg6 the easiest probably so if I
take is got this check and even Queen t1
check
okay I don't have half the time to
consider this more deeply but this
shouldn't be bad i mean green g6 and
queen e 527 are threats against g7 he
needs to cover g7 someone and now i can
take with a rock black resigned yeah
we'll juice fruit g7 some player cannot
prevent that yeah complicated stuff a
very cool defense he found him the
computer just wants to play 94 with a
good game ok g foursome is debatable
probably but interesting maybe here of
course he can take on f 2 a.m. what well
yeah that's it I can just resign you who
this was very bad then and now I woke up
i'm probably probably ok again yeah this
is a cool way to defend but this is now
a greenish sri looks to look wrong to me
he probably should just just get back
book takes maybe then grab here still g5
this is what the computer wants to do
yeah black handsome quite some player in
it sets opposite color bishops porn it's
not relevant but but here in the game it
did it got very very tricky yeah here
the computer already started to loss
after h5 this Bishop g7 the others I'm i
considered Jackie this is a disaster and
here yeah Bishop g7 this is easy i am
this is what I played I didn't want to
spend much more time f6 seems to hold
but this loses queen d successor plus 10
in the computer that's always very
merciless here alright so um yeah an
interesting game but g4 was of course
complete completely wrong if he can play
yeah okay I can take with the pawn yeah
it's playable but I wanted to play here
of course to get the diagonal open and
now we can just kill me with native to
alright thanks for watching